what we're going to do in this video is
get some practice comparing numbers
especially positive and negative numbers
so for each of these pairs of numbers i
want you to either write a less than
sign or a greater than sign or just
think about which of these two is
greater than the other pause this video
and see if you can work through these
four pairs
all right now let's do it together
so let's first compare negative seven
fourths to negative three-fourths and
i'm going to try to do that by
visualizing them on a number line
so let me draw a straighter line there
we go
let's see they're both negative which
means they're both to the left of zero
so i'll focus on the left of zero so
that's
zero
and let's see they're both given in
fourths and we need to go all the way to
seven fourths less than zero so let me
think of each of these as a fourth
so one
two
three
four that would be negative one
one
two
three
four that would be negative two and
that's enough for us but i could keep
going if i liked now where is negative
seven fourths on this number line
well i just said each of these is a
fourth so negative one
fourth two fourths three fourths
four fourths five fourths
six fourths seven fourths so this right
over here is negative
seven fourths and where is negative
three-fourths on the number line
negative one-fourth negative two-fourths
negative three-fourths
so which one is greater
well we can see that negative
three-fourths is to the right of
negative seven-fourths so negative
three-fourths is greater or that
negative seven-fourths is less than
negative three-fourths so i'll put a
less than right over here
let's do this next example we're going
to compare 0.6 to negative 1.8 if you
haven't already given it a shot or if
this previous example helped inspire
something in you give it another shot
and then we'll do it together
so let's draw
a number line again
and
let me put
0
right over here
that's 1
and that's 2
this is negative 1
this is negative 2
and actually let me make half marks here
so we can get a little bit closer to
thinking about
where these two numbers sit on the
number line i'll start with 0.6
0.6 is you could view that as 6 tenths
it's a little bit more than 5 tenths a
little bit more than a half so 0.6 is
going to be roughly right around here on
our number line
0.6 and where is negative 1.8
well it's negative so it's going to be
to the left of 0 and we're going to go
1.8 to the left so this is negative 1.
this is negative 2 that's too far this
is negative 1.5 negative 1.8 is going to
be roughly let me do this in this color
right over here it's going to be roughly
right over there negative 1.8 and so you
can see that it is left of
0.6 on our number line and so negative
1.8 is less than 0.6 or 0.6 is greater
than negative 1.8
let's do more examples here let's
compare these two numbers
well once again let me put them on a
number line and i want to show you that
the number line does not have to go left
right it could go up down
so let's try that and i'll do it in a
different color
so
i'll make a line like this
and
i am going to
have let's call this
zero
right over here and so this is one
this is two
this is negative one
this is negative 2.
now where is 2 and 1 5 on the number
line so that is positive 1 positive 2
and then we're going to go about a 5th
so that'll get us roughly
right over there
and then where is negative one and one
tenth
well we're not going to go below zero so
negative one and we're going to go
another one tenth beyond that below zero
so it's going to be roughly around there
so that is negative one and one-tenth
and so we can see that negative one and
one-tenth is less than positive two and
one-fifth or positive two and one-fifth
is greater than negative 1 and 1 10.
let's do one last example comparing
these two numbers here and actually i
can extend this number line
right over here and i should be able to
fit
both of these numbers so let me try to
do that so i'm going to extend it
this is negative 3 right over here
so where would negative 1.5 sit well
we're going below zero so that's
negative one
negative 1.5 would be another half it'd
be right in between negative 1 and
negative 2. so negative 1.5
is right over there and where would
negative 2.5 be
well we go negative 1 negative 2 and
then another half so this right over
here is negative 2.5
and we could see very clearly that
negative 1.5 is higher than negative 2.5
so it is also
greater
and we're done